So you're going to need to update the save profile
method in the Conference API class so that, see here where
we get the profile, every time we get the profile
we create new one. Instead of doing that what we need
to do is check if the profile's already in the
data store if it is, get it out, if it isn't
create a new one and then set the values all passed
in by the form. The values that the form doesn't pass
in for new entity, use the default
values and if the entity already existed, then
leave the existing values in the properties. You're also going to need to add a
method in the profile class called update
profile that takes a display name and the
t-shirt size and updates them. If they
haven't changed. That is if they aren't now.